Jarvis Weis is doing what he can to
protect the home he loves but he knows
it probably won't match the might of
what hurricane Florence is set to
unleash it's strong it's here it's
coming we're going to move out this
could be the bull's eye of the hurricane
when it hits normally locals say this
Beach would be full of end-of-season
holidaymakers right now is virtually
empty the buildings along the shoreline
are boarded up the hotels are closed it
seems like most people are heeding the
warning leave Martha and Jed II know
they have to join the exodus they've
come here to reflect on the 50 years
they've been enjoying this beach
watching their children and
grandchildren play
I just am very nice top static because
we have cottages here that we've come to
and we've worked really hard and lots of
love and family memories kept going into
it it's gonna be really I mean it could
be all gone tomorrow not everyone is
following the rules
Joe has stayed put through several
storms route it out that's not the
advice is it no it's not like say a lot
of my friends have been calling me for
they're late like like Joe leave
immediately defiance in the face of this
monster hurricane is largely giving way
to resignation the only safe place is
away from the coastline
even the muscle of military hardware is
no match for the punch
Florence is set
helicopters at Fort Bragg have been
removed to safety the latest updates
show Florence increasing in size and
strength it's heading straight for the
Carolinas and could bring with it
devastation that hasn't been seen in
decades Amanda Walker Sky News North
Carolina